the college of southern nevada is  helping students succeed during the  coronavirus pandemic  is giving out free laptops to all  first-time students who  are attending full-time with most  classes online you know some students  are facing  learning barriers because they don't  have the proper tools and technology  most of our classes are requiring that  level of connectivity  so csn is standing up as the first enchi  institution to be offering  this type of investment that we're  making in our students because we  know how much those students and their  families are investing  in them now these students they can keep  their laptops for their time at csn and  even when they graduate